do you think this is the time where the
party needs to harden its position on
Europe if you like or are you happy with
David Cameron's renegotiate and
recommend yes position well I think the
Prime Minister's position is absolutely
right and it's a very clear pledge that
he will seek to renegotiate and then
whatever the outcomes of those
renegotiations are we'll put it to the
country by the end of 2017 and I think
that's something that very much unites
the Conservative Party so the majority
may be relatively small but I think this
is an issue that we're going to see a
great deal of unity on and as things
stand if there was no change or one
person who would want to get out as
things stand at the moment I think the
balance of advantage to this country is
with leaving the European Union but
let's see how the Prime Minister gets on
on the renegotiations he's been
successful in terms of getting us out of
the euro bailout mechanism at the
beginning of the last Parliament
introducing the referendum lock despite
being in coalition with the Liberal
Democrats at the time he's been
underestimated at every step of the way
so let's see what he can achieve me what
needs to change in your view well I
think free movement of people is an
issue that not just this country but
many other countries in the EU needs we
need me need to have a look at and less
political interference in domestic
affairs so let's see how he gets on with
that but either way it'll be for you and
I and the rest of the British public to
make a judgment call on that when the
referendum comes by the end of 2017 and
my votes and your vote will be just the
same as the Prime Minister supposed to
the ballot box and what about the
European Convention on Human Rights not
directly related to the EU but seems odd
that conservatives are so anxious to
take away rights from the citizens but
it's not about taking away rights it's
about rebalancing rights and certainly
many of the people I have spoken to on
the doorstep of Crawley my constituency
and I know across the country are very
concerned at the way the Human Rights
Act has operated since it was introduced
in the late 1990s it's not about taking
away rights but replacing the Human
Rights Acts and the way that it doesn't
function correctly and what agency
what's the problem with it well and
introducing
a British Bill of Rights many people
feel that it isn't very balanced in
terms of things like the victim versus
the traitor in certain criminal cases
again coming back to the case of
immigration there have been some
problems with article 8 being abused on
the European Convention so you know
these days many people in this country
end up with fewer citizens rights than
those in Germany or France for example
well I think this country has a long and
proud history of developing human rights
and the rights of the citizen over the
states over many centuries particularly
in this 800th year of the Magna Carta
that's been an evolution and I think
this country has a proud of history than
say some many other countries in Europe
on the issue of human rights and this
with if David Cameron offers you a job
in his ministerial shuffle what would
you like it to be what would be your
dream I I will play my part in ensuring
that this incoming Conservative
government is able to deliver for the
people of Great Britain and I will play
whatever parts I'm asked to do in that
how difficult do you think it is can be
managing a small majority well small
majorities historically have been
difficult much analogy has been made in
terms of this election being similar to
the 92 election but i think it's
different in the fact that we're not
just at the tail end of many years of a
Conservative government and actually the
parties united around these cages so
well IIIi can't see a cause for a bail
of rebellion at the moment I have
rebelled in the past when it's when I
haven't agreed with the policy of the
government but I don't see any policies
that I disagree with at the moment
whether it be English votes EU
referendum a British Bill of Rights and
sort of the Human Rights Act staying on
course to recover the economy all of
these things I'm very much fully signed
up to okay thank you very much for
joining us